hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm brandi
price today I we were just watching a
video from Tyrone Magnus his video is
called a more than just a reactor Brandi
and I took it upon ourselves to do the
sequel called we're just we're just know
we're gonna call this we're more than
reactors yeah see it's plural that's
what you do with sequels maybe add more
and now there's sexual dynamic because
of Brandi cuz she's woman in tyrone
monsta uh-huh no nothing he does he said
you're pretty cute okay pretty cute does
not mean that you want to bone someone
that's what it means to a guy maybe not
to women when women are talking to men
sea we offer all kinds of banter on this
channel oh the main driving source for
both of our channels is the reactions
that is currently what's most popular
you did it because people kept asking
you to try to do it so yeah so you did
it because of that I did it too because
I saw Gator Martin do it and I was like
this looks like fun I can't do that so I
did it and then subscribers were like
yes do more and then I was getting a lot
of subscribers from it and so I know
it's the main driving source but I will
also say what really separates us from a
typical reaction channel like Tyrone
gives commentary on it you know but and
I feel confident enough in our
commentary to title almost every video
reaction and review that's what it is
you know we react to it sure it's our
first time watching but it's also an
instant trailer review or video
discussion you know exactly like how it
makes you feel most of mine are like how
it makes me yeah exactly watch it cuz
it's like people want you to watch viral
videos but most of the time I'll title
my videos reaction and discussion I'll
be honest with people if there's not
much you know commentary there's usually
always commentary but if there's not
much I just title it reaction I'm aware
that we we do put a lot of talking into
this review and I'm another thing to
that kind of upsets me is people think
that we don't do any work at all oh wow
that's so I work most of the day on
YouTube yeah you know like you really do
and a lot of people don't realize that
and it's it takes a while to put videos
together it's one you have to record
them to you have to edit them then you
have to upload them and then you have to
edit them once they're on YouTube and
then setting up takes time to to get
your videos done and everything like you
have to buy equipment and stuff you know
it's more than just like we're sitting
at a laptop or something right yeah then
you gotta edit them you got export then
we got upload them you got to annotate
them to act like a lot I'll to do yeah
and it so each video takes a while and
the other Lane like an hour hour and a
half i would say for each video yeah
absolutely from the editing to the
uploading it takes probably an hour to
two hours you know we work a lot they're
like why don't you do with it anymore I
was like well I do have a full-time job
yeah and that's the other thing about
people whose channels are mainly
reaction driven is they think putting
doing a reaction video takes like a few
minutes for us to do but it actually
takes like a couple hours per video yeah
and um it takes a couple hours per video
so after you know I tried that thing
where I was like you know if I just
start talking I'll remember it talking
about people want quantity to more than
just quality videos they expect like a
lot of youtubers will post like once a
week a lot even once a month but from
people who mainly have reaction German
channels you post one video a day like
oh you're you're lagging you know yeah
you're slacking yeah I was every time
I've taken a trip somewhere I am still
doing videos you know everywhere I've
taken it i went to the i went to san
diego for comic-con I barely got to do
like other stuff because I was still
working on the videos right any of
yourselves happy yeah of course here's
the man so much but what I will also say
is damn it happen again not again yeah
i'll also say that once a week i usually
post a video that is not a reaction
video okay whether it be movie review or
Omnitech or the movie news that's what i
mean like let's do it Tyrone did let's
look at our channel page hahaha this is
my
I uh tough guy voice okay yeah so if you
uh go to our page the real rejects
you'll see a playlist called new to the
channel to the channel tyra Magnus of is
turning into Sylvester Stallone family
are you going to do the gin but anyway
there's a playlist called new to the
channel Tyrone brokers channel down i
figure we had the same four hours not so
new to the channel because there are a
lot of [ __ ] videos on the real
rejects and if you go to New the channel
I like to show that there's diversity if
you come to the channel yes there's the
trailer reactions of course and the
reviews and then you got like a couple
of skits up here and you got discussion
videos that are not reactions and then
if you go down you know you got your
popular uploads I'm like Tyrone all my
popular uploads are reactions you gotta
be honest to you i'm scrolling through
the channel trailer finally after like
six rows of reaction so yes I'm aware
it's the main driving source but that
doesn't negate the fact that like you do
other videos still get a lot of views
you know like the movie reviews I do
tend to perform pretty well yeah you
know you're the terms of thousands the
dude then I candies IRA this is a 30 to
50,000 up to 100,000 I have one movie
review that I think is that 40,000 views
I see and then if you look at the rest
of the channel there's movie news of the
week and three minutes or less and that
takes a lot of work to film and edit
they're moving these of the week you
know I try that green screen [ __ ] haha
you know that's how much work I put into
it is I pin a green screen against the
wall I don't even set the polls and [ __ ]
I just pin it then they did along like
yeah [ __ ] yeah no 15 minutes setting up
bowls have you ever tried setting up my
green screen it's so annoying because of
all the polls you got to do no good
that's why you just pin it you got
spoiler reviews and movie news and
rumors discussions and jerry has
playlists on this channel that a lot of
people don't realize that Jerry is the
number two on this channel you know he
is the Robin to my Batman he is the
Spock to my Kirk he is the Jackie Chan
to my Chris Tucker or is it reversed no
one or the other one or the other
depending on who wants top billing
exactly we got short films and sketches
and that does not take a couple hours to
do those take a [ __ ] long walk well
because you're filming for hours yeah
yeah and my highest viewed one has 50
1230-1 views and then second highest
unique 40 8776 than 43,000 so there's a
lot of these perform pretty well I think
you want to be naked in all of them I
there's a thing if you notice in my
thumbnails i'm usually yelling all right
naked or i'm naked and then like Tyrone
I got unboxing videos and I got video
blogs to just posted a video blog of
VidCon mmm yeah total blast total blast
yeah please give me free tickets again
next year on I saw your a human bowling
that was pretty fun hey man nothing
beats watching 13 year old girls obsess
over their favorite pretty boy on you
too beautiful i bet i was there a line
who the [ __ ] is that I don't know he is
but he's [ __ ] beautiful so yeah
there's that there's all that so I think
were pretty creative and we do a lot
more than that and brandi's channel she
has the new to the baseline beatnik and
you know she assembled some videos that
give a good idea of her channel which
also feature a monologue and uh this is
that's a short film that I did um I
shall watch it sometime yeah and if you
look at her playlist its trailer talk so
there's other reaction and reviews and
then the reviews and rambling or her
movie reviews and her popular uploads
are like me also reaction
yeah we're most of a more reactions
mm-hmm man Tyrone really has us in that
department doesn't it so she has like
monologues and short film she does
monologue mondays that she's really I
agreed we had I do is she if she does
them it's on a monday behind the camera
think she's helped shoot commercials
she's done and video she's been on for
the real rejects which are all reaction
video yeah so except for this one this
is our first non reaction video together
when did she know too that's not true
cuz we did one for Sally's channel F
short film no but I mean for love your
channel yeah ok who's Sally Oh Sally
Sally salamander yeah I'll mander Sally
yeah yeah yeah um redhead yeah she's
cute she's on your channel all the time
you know who she is she's only been only
a hundred ten videos I know that's not
that many how many have you been in
ready you've been in 54 videos 55 to do
Richard anyway for news channel you can
subscribe you the real rejects you can
subscribe to brandy prices channel if
you like what you hear you could follow
us on Facebook Instagram Twitter vine
and periscope whatever I don't know she
has all that doesn't periscope Irvine
well that's very disappointing I have
Bynes where I show more creativity hey
and I think of that I create vines delon
wit de stacks hey Ryan I'm a beginner
reactor good but started YouTube skits
and stuff in 2012 cool man you was the
one who made watch reactions like Gator
when you first started I became addicted
because of your funny sex jokes you know
one day there's gonna be a time where
someone says you make funny jokes
everyone's like funny sex jokes are
funny dick jokes well that's what they
primarily are I know but sometimes i
make other jokes right
what if you watch our skits they are
mainly not filled with sex jokes okay
well that okay i can give you that one
but when i do these videos i don't know
they just generate reactions from the
audience so I just like sometimes I just
like I'm just gonna say something
because I'm gonna like to read the
comment about ways my youtube channel is
legendary bigs and you have aronica have
a peaceful dating life how the [ __ ]
would you know that and you all better
get married oh you saying like as a
suggestion as a suggestion alright he
sounds like he's making a declarative
statement right guys but he's think he
means it as in hey you guys have a good
day it's kind of like have a good day
dude you guys gotta check out the
legendary bigs you know what oh oh he's
like an adorable little black guy his
face is so awesome okay one that's a
show
[ __ ] are we watching you guys got to
subscribe to legendary big kids I don't
know what the bug is going on right now